luis castillo has been brilliant
for about a month now his full season
numbers from western and southern
but they particularly peak over the last
month where
barry larkin his era just over 1.7 one
of the best
in baseball in june yes john he's been
really good this last month and
his ability to pitch to all quadrants of
the of the plate
i think that was really the turning
point for him in this season
now he'll deal with fernando tatis
junior runner off swinging the miss
throw down
pretty good one the tag dropped he's out
strike about throwing that double play
caught stealing 2-4 oh this is the type
of pitch you want to be able to throw
on right here tyler stevenson gets a
nice
fastball out away from him where he can
extend
and make the transfer strike him out
throw him out three balls and two
strikes payoff
weak pop kyle farmer
minimum faced first frame castillo finds
it
the reds will be at the plate ryan
weathers returns to cincinnati
to fulfill a childhood dream facing his
father's former team
indeed first one and two to winker with
castiano's waiting on deck
there's a head here we'll see what he
does elevates and that's strike three
got the high strike call winker doesn't
like it at all
spins out of the box is gonna say some
stuff to tripp gibson on the way by
strikeout number one from ryan weathers
remember talking about filling in the
dot the white dot
that one fills in and it looks like it's
right at the top of the strike zone
you know a lot of times hitters are
going to hit that ball out of the
ballpark they like to get on top of that
pitch and set it on its way
but yet if taken yeah they give an
earful to the umpire
and one out that'll bring up tyler
stevenson
strike over the inside corner that is
strike three second strikeout for
weathers two down
two paul third strikes and ollie
stevenson's overly enamored
with this call you know what the net
caught all plate
yep that's a great pitch freeze fastball
right there
straighten them up a little bit
definitely a strike plenty of the strike
zone
it is first and third now with two down
two balls two strikes to
joey bottom runner goes and a line drive
to second base on a hop
it's picked by cudaworth who throws to
first to get votto
and they strand two to the reds weathers
gets out of the gym we're scoreless
after one
and now you got the pitcher spot luis
castillo faces loaded
scoreless game nobody out 02. castillo
swings chops into tatis
leaping snare overhand lob to third
that's all they'll get
lopez scores rbi luis castillo on the
fielder's choice one-nothing reds
castillo makes contact that's what you
need in that situation
and really the only play that tatis has
is to throw the third base
a run in two on one out farmer at second
castillo first
to one broken bat shallow right center
coming on grisham tries to deak
extension can't make the play
farmer rounds third he scores bull
gathered and right lobbed in
india goes to second castillo slows it
third
and in between bowl and a hot potato not
held it's two
nothing reds well another ball that's
chipped to the outfield
and you can see grisham with the the
dive in the attempt
another ball not well struck but well
placed
his first hitter of the third inning fly
ball
center field grisham going back and
grisham reaches up to make the catch
right in front of the fence over the
shoulder nicely done
joey vado drives it out to deep left
center field and grisham runs it down on
the dirt of the track
there's some gold out there in that
center field area in cincinnati
playing him on the shortstop side he's
got a beat on it flash look track
and run as hard as you can and then that
last second reach for it
right there to haul it in taking away
extra bases
and says low to the fence full count
three and two to india
swinging a miss ends up striking him out
and that is strikeout number four
for ryan weathers you know hitters can
tell you so much
just by their mannerisms and how they
take pitches remember the pitch prior to
this caught a lot of the plate
that tells me that india does not like
the ball in does he like the ball up and
away you bet he offers it that one
can't catch up to it very late one out
one on
jesse winker who has struck out twice
tonight against weathers
swinging a missile for the third time in
tonight's game jesse winker
strikes out and that's five strikeouts
for weathers winker's frustrated
back-to-back case here for weathers ball
and two strikes
down a third and picked by machado from
one knee the throw
is in time manny machado a defensive
spectacular play laying it out and from
one knee slings it across the diamond
and gets it there
for out number three but manny was just
another remarkable defensive effort
diving towards the line
got up onto one knee threw across his
body
and for the moment at least got
castianos and you know what
no challenge the inning is over smooth
operator over at third base
as good as it gets the tarp on the field
so they are expecting some big time rain
so we're in the midst of a rain delay we
head to the top of the fifth inning
after the rain delay and two nothing
advantage for the reds
fly ball hit in the air to deep center
field back goes aquino
onto the track it's off the wall out of
his reach
machado is going to try and score he
will hosmer stops at third the throw of
the plate is not in time
and it is machado the padres are on the
board
it's a double for profar and the padres
are on the board i'm not sure what
happened to aquino
yeah this was very uh poorly played in
center field he had more room than he
realized
not familiar with the track out there
and a good job by winker backing up
you know the big kid had plenty of room
two out lopez third on a wild pitch
aquino
3-1 into right field
down base head lopez scores
aquino rounds first trucks into second
shuts it down there and rbi double good
bit of hitting by
the punisher love to see aquino run for
a big guy he can run
really well here is tommy pham off the
bench to pinch it
base is filled with friars eighth pitch
of the play to parents coming up
lying to center field to base head from
third base comes machado
hosmer being waved around the throw will
come plateward it's cut off and the
padres have tied the game
a two-run single for tommy pham and the
padres tie it up three to three
and tommy pham comes through big time
ball and two strikes to hosmer with
machado on second two away here's the
pitch
osmer will chop one to third over as
lopez his throw
in the dirt gets away here comes machado
he'll come around and score
hosmer to second base and the padres
take a 4-3 lead
the errant throw and the padres take the
lead in the eighth inning
farmer oh for four against molansen but
he's put the ball in play all four times
so farmer ahead of the count
and comes the 2-0 farmer unloads center
field
that's a deep shot that is gone
to the batter's eye grass tyga
joey votto on deck helmet off in a squat
position blowing the bubbles
watching and waiting now tyler stevenson
give it a huge moment
the reds rookie stevenson to right field
the reds win
third career walk-off hit for the rook
the padres chose to face tyler stevenson
they chose portland